This equation really represents a hyperbola. And it opens up and down. Nice
thinking if you got that correct. Now remember, we want to get the x squared
and y squared term on the same side of the equation. So, I'm going to subtract
2x squared from both sides of the equation. This will leave us with 18 on the
right, and 2y squared minus 2x squared on the left. Since we have a subtraction
sign between the y squared and the x squared term, we know the conic is a
hyperbola. And since this y squared term comes first, we know that our
hyperbola opens up and it opens down. We can put this equation into the general
form that we recognize, by dividing each term by 18. We'll have y squared
divided by 9 minus x squared divided by 9 equals 1. And just to be sure, I can
show you that each of these equations represent the same exact hyperbola. The
equations are just written in different forms.